[Music]
a lot of times when i think about
um my best experiences uh
cinematically you know as a fan a lot of
my great memories have been in imax
theaters
and when i make films like fast my goal
is to be able to
hopefully create something that people
can enjoy in a huge
cinematic experience with you know
their friends and family and really
immerse themselves and i think imax is
the perfect format to
enjoy that in
[Music]
we've always we made a pact with each
other that if we were able to earn
another
chapter that we were always going to
challenge ourselves so
it was very important to me to be able
to do something that we haven't done
before and i think that the exploration
of
our theme of family but through blood
you know is something that we have never
done and i think that
presents an experience and tones
and structure of a fast movie
that people are not going to be used to
it and i'm really excited for the fans
to see this film
you know i feel like it's 20 years in
the making i think for me to be away and
come back
i really am very proud because when we
started off we were not
obviously not where we are today and now
we have this amazing group of
of characters in our universe and also
just you know the
the narratives and their journey has
really kind of expanded in a way that
i feel like this this movie not only
connects it
but makes a promise that they're just so
many more kind of compelling and fun
stories to be had
and uh that i hope they will enjoy
you